[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
recital de Memphis depay en la victoria
de Países Bajos el jugador del Barcelona
fue la gran figura del 20 sobre senegal
que dejó a su equipo empatado con
Ecuador en la cima del grupo a tenemos
análisis
Gareth Bale salva gales sin extremis
hasta el minuto 82 perdí el equipo
británico frente a Estados Unidos y la
estrella de la mls se encarga de poner
la paridad France 24 estuvo presente en
ese encuentro
Inglaterra fue un huracán la joven
selección británica produjo la primera
goleada del mundial un 6-2 ante Irán en
la apertura del grupo B desde dos años
reportan nuestra enviada especial
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio sasso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Omar buenas tardes Un gusto
saludarte a ti y a toda la gente de
france24 También aprovecho de darle la
bienvenida a nuestra enviada especial
Natalia Ruiz quien nos trae todos los
detalles de primera mano de lo que
ocurre en Qatar Saludos Natalia
Hola muy buenas noches También para
todos desde doha el grupo a ya tiene a
dos equipos empatados En la cima luego
de resultados de países de los del
resultado de Países Bajos sobre senegal
un 2 a 0 que tuvo un sello particular un
Memphis sepay protagonista en los dos
goles y un héroe inesperado el portero
Andrés que llegó a Qatar como tercer
guardameta de este equipo de países
asoció a los 39 con su compañero del
Barcelona Frankie de John que habilitó a
codycaptor para el 1-0 ya en el
descuento de países escapó forzó el
error de la defensa senegalesa y David
clase en líquido para el 2-0 le
preguntamos a nuestra enviada especial
Natalia Ruiz qué podemos rescatar como
lo más destacado de este resultado
Así es pues ustedes bien lo decía de
Omar y es que Franky de John fue uno de
los fue el jugador que quizás más se
destacó en este partido fue digamos el
el maestro del tiempo el que manejó
todos los tiempos de ese partido tanto
en la defensa Como ofensivamente así que
queda mucho por rescatar de él
justamente también hablaba usted de el
jugador que marcó el primer tanto de
este partido
con ese gol y por supuesto ahí también
fue un pase gol de de John a esto hay
que sumarle igualmente Pues el esfuerzo
de senegal este era un partido
complicado para los actuales campeones
de África sobre todo pues sin poder
contar con Memphis eh Perdón sin poder
contar con con su estrella Así que fue
un poquito complicado este este este
encuentro a lucié que tuvo que hacer un
cambios en su 11 inicial esadio Mané por
supuesto y también pues él hizo un
cambio interesante en el medio campo
conseyate que finalmente salió lesionado
y que parece que es una lesión bastante
importante él había optado por cuyate en
vez de el jugador de Marsella Ahora hay
que saber Y es que se esperaba quizás un
poco más de Países Bajos porque ese
primer tiempo que finalmente se fueron
sin goles ambos equipos pues deja mucho
que desear porque no había no había
definición alguna ni de los senegaleses
ni de los neerlandeses Así que esas son
ajustes que hay que hacer antes de El
próximo partido porque las cosas pueden
ser un poquito complicadas para los
Países Bajos que se esperaban fueran
digamos los grandes favoritos de este
grupo y justamente tendrán que medirse
ante Ecuador la aproximación es el
próximo viernes Perdón mientras sea que
pues eh será el siguiente partido será
también pues acatar frente a
frente a senegal Sí precisamente Octavio
en la línea de lo que
Natalia que termina siendo un resultado
Tal vez engañoso porque ganó Países
Bajos pero no denunció senegal qué
ajustes tuvo que hacer a Lucifer para
lograr ese toma y dame que se vio
permanentemente un este senegal que que
no des desilusionó a pesar de la
ausencia de estadio Mané Sí lo que pasa
es que para para el mundo entero Omar el
hecho de ver a senegal quizás mucha
gente no lo había visto no lo tenía en
cuenta pero estamos hablando del actual
campeón de África un equipo que que
realmente juega muy bien al fútbol que
ha podido consolidar un fútbol de manejo
de pelota con con facilidad con llegada
al ataque evidentemente con la salida de
esadio Mané este equipo pierde toda la
potencia que tenía la mitad de cancha
hacia arriba pero aún así como tiene
buen manejo de pelota como es un equipo
atrevido trató de buscarle la la vuelta
al partido y lo enfrentó mano a mano a
Países Bajos que al final yo creo que no
se sorprende porque Países Bajos conocía
del mundial de de senegal y por eso el
partido se dio ida y vuelta porque los
dos equipos sabían que tenían que ir a
buscar los tres puntos sabían que tenían
que ir a ganar luego el resultado de
Ecuador era el Duelo entre los dos
grandes imaginemos que este partido se
jugaba con sabio Mané los dos eran los
favoritos de del grupo Entonces por esa
razón hicieron el juego que hicieron
para tratar de doblegarse uno al otro
potencia potencia sin tener un digamos
un límite en ese sentido de todas
maneras Bueno lo que terminó privando
fue la jerarquía del equipo de Países
Bajos que es diferente a la que tiene
hoy senegal que le tocó además hacer
ajustes también de Países Bajos Porque
Luis van gaal sorprende con esta
alineación de un jugador que hasta no
hace mucho no tenía equipo como el
portero noper que qué valoraciones se
pueden hacer sobre este país es bajo que
se vio hoy sí un equipo que apostó a eso
a la calidad individual de algunos de
sus jugadores quizás de los referentes
de vidrio Bandai como hablabas de
Memphis depay que son jugadores que
normalmente están peleando en equipos
grandes de liga de campeones tienen una
jerarquía por encima el resto y y Países
Bajos apostó a los últimos 10 minutos de
partido contra el cansancio del rival
contra el agotamiento físico que también
tenía senegal como para imponer su juego
y tratar de llevarse el resultado y eso
fue lo que terminó pasando un equipo que
tiene una potencia física diferente a la
de los africanos y que por el juego
aéreo abrió la cuenta y que luego
terminó marcando Esa diferencia sobre el
final pero yo creo que la palabra para
definir ahumares es jerarquía Países
Bajos tiene mucha más jerarquía hoy que
senegan bien este resultado Deja como
decíamos un empate perfecto en el
liderato del grupo a por pues Ecuador y
Países Bajos registraron victorias
idénticas sobre catarres senegal
respectivamente a las puertas de ese
enfrentamiento del que hablaban Natalia
Ruiz enfrentamiento directo entre
punteros previsto para el viernes y un
astro de la mls ha sido artífice del
empate entre gales y Estados Unidos
tingüea El hijo del Astro de Liberia y
hoy presidente de ese país George juega
abrió el marcador para los
norteamericanos pero el fichaje estrella
de la mls temporada de Gareth Bale puso
el empate cuando faltaban 8 minutos para
el pitazo final Natalia sin duda un
resultado que los norteamericanos
lamentan porque es una victoria que se
deja escapar
Así es edumar porque todo ese primer
tiempo Pues gales fue prácticamente
inexistente los Estados Unidos muy
rápidos muy ofensivos y luego pues
finalmente gales parecía que caminara un
poco que subiera todo ese primer tiempo
se jugó de hecho en su campo mientras
que hay que decir que en el segundo
tiempo Pues el partido se jugó más en el
campo de los estadounidenses como
ustedes bien lo decía pues este gol de
team juega quedó hizo explotar en júbilo
este este estadio que ustedes Ven a mis
espaldas hay que saber que también es
interesante la animación que había en
este en este estadio que parecía un
estadio más en cualquier otro lugar del
mundo que no fuera dos lleno de
estadounidenses lleno también de galeses
que por fin esperaban ver a su elección
después de 64 años como usted bien lo
dijo en la introducción pero
efectivamente Pues estimula a pesar de
que hace aquello que su padre no logró
que fue mandar un marcar un gol en una
copa de la un mundo pues dejaron pasar
la oportunidad de quedarse finalmente
con tres importantes a sabiendas de que
van a tener que enfrentarse a ese hueso
duro de Robert que será Inglaterra y por
supuesto de alguna manera pues este gol
que llega ahí al final ese ese penalti
de Babel quizás ustedes antes hablaban
de jerarquía para Países Bajos aquí tal
vez como experiencia un poco viejo zorro
de Vela al que no se le vio demasiado
durante el primer tiempo pero sí en el
segundo pues eh hace que de alguna
manera este resultado este empate uno
por uno pues sea más con un saborcito de
de Victoria para los alcalces que pero
que para los estadounidenses que no la
van a tener fácil en ese segundo partido
Octavio la mls normalmente es percibida
como una liga de segunda si se quiere
pero resulta que en este mundial es la
quinta que más jugadores aporta a Qatar
2022 actuaciones como esta de Bale
pueden digamos abrir una puerta para
evaluar de una manera distinta esta liga
Sí ya ya hay que ya hay que hacerlo el
crecimiento de esa liga es notable la
cantidad de jugadores que tiene dentro
de del mundial lo marca hoy antes del
partido
muy saludado Babel con varios compañeros
de su equipo de Los Ángeles Fútbol Club
que son los actuales campeones uno ve un
mar el crecimiento de esa liga también
en función de los hijos de los grandes
jugadores y aún no se siente viejo está
el hijo de huella el hijo de reina el
hijo de David Ferreira colombiano
también jugando en ese equipo entonces
la mls está produciendo muchísimo
talento esta selección de los Estados
Unidos es la más talentosa de los
últimos seguro 20 30 años a diferencia
está en la experiencia que pueden ir
acumulando que poco a poco lo Irán
haciendo que jugadores como público o
Weston mckenning que están jugando en
grandes equipos de del mundo pero sin
duda alguna Aquí está la muestra de la
preparación de Gareth Bale en la mls
para para el mundial muchos se dudaba
sobre eso pero Gareth Bale es un jugador
de estos que uno no puede nunca no
tenerlo en cuenta porque te puede marcar
la diferencia así sea en un penal
entonces la mls hoy es una liga para
para tener en cuenta
la primera goleada del mundial de 14
produjo en el estadio califa
internacional fue el 612 Inglaterra
sobre una selección iraní que no cantó
el himno nacional una manifestación que
se ha hecho recurrente para los iraníes
en eventos deportivos goles de
cayosaka dos veces
convirtieron al equipo de los tres
leones en un conjunto con el que hay que
contar Natalia usted también estuvo
presente en ese partido Inglaterra
podemos decir que comienza a lucir como
candidato
Pues bien Podría decirse En todo caso
Digamos que bien puedes comenzar
comienzo muy bien digamos este está el
hecho de ser el favorito digamos de ese
grupo En todo caso es el equipo con con
más hombros con masa bagaje en ese en
ese grupo efectivamente 6-062 perdón
pues se muestra una victoria bastante
amplia Ahora hay que entender también
que Irán de todas maneras marcó dos
goles con ese penalti ya sobre el final
de ese partido y de hecho después de de
este partido dio una conferencia de
prensa les dijo que era un buen inicio
para esta selección para los tres leones
pero que habían perdido la concentración
quizás también porque hubo unos alargues
importantes en el día de hoy en los
diferentes en los diferentes partidos y
pues esto hizo también que quizás si
hubiera perdido esa Esa esa lucidez de
que les faltó y él dijo que normalmente
Pues los ingleses no debían haber dejado
que Irán pudiera descontar ya con eso
con esos dos goles de la Estrella iraní
Así que digamos que empieza así con pie
derecho esas ambiciones con las que
llegó aquí a Inglaterra que se quedó
Hace cuatro años aportas de la final
pero pues habrá habrá que esperar
precisamente ese segundo partido ante
los Estados Unidos a ver otro Duelo
anglosajón que puede ser bastante
interesante y dos estilos de juego bien
diferentes
Octavio Cómo podemos explicar un repunte
como el que ha mostrado Inglaterra en
este primer partido a la luz por ejemplo
de resultados como el que tuvo en la
Liga de Naciones lo necesitaban
precisamente necesitaban un partido así
una goleada para sacarse ese peso encima
porque llegaban con muchísimas dudas la
gente sobre todo el periodismo británico
el periodismo europeo estaba muy encima
de esa selección que había defraudado si
se puede decir así en la Liga de
Naciones y que evidentemente le generaba
esa duda sobre todo en cuanto a los
goles porque es un equipo que no venía
marcando goles y hoy tenía la
posibilidad de de triturar a Irán de la
manera en que lo hizo incluso esta sele
la menos inglesa de los últimos tiempos
porque incluso la mayoría de los
jugadores que hoy marcaron goles son o
descendientes de africanos o de islas
del Caribe o irlandeses como Jack grills
terminan marcando una diferencia
potencial en el juego aprovecharon
también el descontrol de Irán que tiene
la cabeza en otro lado que está muy
complicados anímicamente que no ha sido
fácil la presión que recibirán
aprovecharon y le pasaron por encima
incluso yo creo que ese día y debe estar
lamentándose que le marcan ese gol de
última hora porque esa diferencia de
goles lo podía dejar muy tranquilo al
seleccionado inglés Así que yo creo que
Inglaterra necesitaba de eso necesitaba
sacarse ese peso encima y de aquí en
adelante seguramente va a salir lo mejor
de su fútbol con este resultado
Inglaterra se coloca de líder en el
grupo B por delante de gales y Estados
Unidos y con una diferencia de goles
como decía Octavio que puede ayudar más
adelante y este martes debuta una de las
elecciones llamadas a ser protagonista
en este mundial hablamos de Argentina
que enfrentará vía Saudita una Argentina
en la que la gran figura Lionel Messi ha
confirmado que este su quinto mundial
Será también el último así espero su
fanaticada ese partido
la primera que estoy acá y puedo
compartir con esta gente de tantos
kilómetros de casa Así que es lo único
que espero ganarla y bueno nada de
compartir con la gente todo esto que es
hermoso y que nos une tanto y que nos
hace tan particular pero no tengo ni
otra expectativa gana la copa y que nos
vamos loco en Buenos Aires Natalia había
preocupación en Argentina hasta no hace
mucho porque meses había estado
entrenando solo y no como parte del
equipo pero hoy el clima es de alivio
que ha dicho meses sobre sus razones
para trabajar de forma diferenciada como
lo hizo
lo que hizo fue despejar a dudas dudas
que había muchas de la prensa porque la
prensa internacional había ido a ese
primer entrenamiento de los argentinos y
habían quedado defraudados de no Ver a
Messi pero sobre todo con muchísimas
preguntas y pues el argentino hoy de una
manera bastante es Serena mostrando de
alguna manera lo que el mismo decía que
quizás ha madurado y sabe muy bien Ahora
Cómo poder afrontar lo que es una prueba
como estar aquí en un mundial de fútbol
les dijo que simplemente ya se había
preparado que él había hecho su trabajo
si había cuidado y que estaba en muy
buena forma no solamente físicamente
sino también a nivel personal y sobre
todo que usted lo decía así dice que es
probablemente su último mundial y que lo
que él vino a hacer fue a disfrutar
también este momento además de esto
también dijo que sentía que este era un
equipo muy parecido a la de Brasil en el
2014 en cuanto digamos a la economía la
unidad al entendimiento que hay así que
pues escucho un Leonel mucho más sereno
se habla mucho que después de esa
victoria de Argentina en la pasada copa
América pues Us digamos ese sentimiento
de liberación pero vamos a ver si eso es
lo que va a haberse reflejado el día de
mañana porque finalmente pues es su
último mundial Así que es su última
oportunidad de alcanzar la gloria
Natalia le agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros
y Octavio le preguntamos brevemente esta
Argentina viene con una épica después de
la obtención de esa copa América el año
pasado después de cuatro finales
consecutivas perdidas qué podemos
esperar de ella llegó el día Omar llegó
el día que ha estado esperando Argentina
y muchos lugares del mundo va a debutar
mes y va a debutar el seleccionado Luis
Celeste creo que es el partido clave
porque de aquí saldrá el ánimo de
Argentina para el resto del mundial si
puede tener un gran partido frente
Arabia Saudita va a caminar al equipo de
Messi tranquilo como gran favorito para
la copa del mundo Octavio lloviendo nos
reencontramos mañana aquí de nuevo en
diario el mundial y seguimos con una
selección de noticias de este campeonato
mundial de fútbol para variar Neymar ha
causado polémica el Astro del París
saint-germain se dejó ver con un short
que muestra el escudo de la
confederación brasileña de fútbol con
seis estrellas en lugar de las cinco
copas del mundo que ha levantado hasta
el momento la ganaría un gesto que
aficionados de equipos rivales han
interpretado como una falta de respeto
su compañero Richardson salió en su
defensa
el campeón del mundo Francia disputa su
primer partido frente a Australia será
la hora de demostrar la capacidad de
superar los infortunios de los últimos
tiempos y la pérdida de gran parte de
esa selección y de la columna vertebral
del medio campo
[Música]
mañana se tendremos esos dos encuentros
de
El debut de Francia también el debut de
Argentina en la continuación de este
campeonato mundial de fútbol y hasta
aquí llega esta emisión del Diario del
mundial los invitamos a continuar con la
programación de France 24 y acompañarnos
Este martes en un nuevo especial para
repasar la máxima cita del fútbol
mundial
[Música]